welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Vasa in phase four the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has been officially push back
with Black Widow delayed for a May to
November 6 2020 with the turtles and the
other title shifted back one scheduled
slot to Disney tried to stop in this
blow by announcing that Captain Marvel 2
will be coming out July 2022 which great
yeah cool but now we have someone else
to blame a few weeks ago we called this
hypothetical scenario to no longer a
hypothetical and like you're feeling
this is yet another thing for us that
we're not too thrilled about but we
wanted to give you a quick update
breaking down everything about this new
schedule and what this new updated
timeline tells us about the stories of
each of these titles says yeah we
actually did learn a few things here ok
let's start with the new MCU phase four
calendar Black Widow
moved from May to November 6 2020 that
was the turtle's old release date now
the Eternals is dropping February 12
2021 shang-chi and alleged to the ten
rings moving back to May 7 2021 Doctor
Strange and multiverse of madness moving
back from May to November 5th 2021 Thor
11 Thunder is moving back from November
2021 to February 18 20 22 now Black
Panther 2 was set at may 6 2012 and it
is staying there for now Disney also
announced a release date for Captain
Marvel 2 July 8 2022
that leaves the MCU spider-man 3 doubly
titled spider-man work from home
whatever while it's a joint Marvel
production it's actually being produced
by a different studio Sony now Sony move
did spider-man spin-off Morbius from
July 20 22 March 19 20 21 sony plan to
commence production for spider-man 3
this summer and if they can stick to
that spider-man 3 may remain in its July
22 1 in one spot now what about the
Marvel Disney Plus series at the moment
it remains unclear but it all depends on
how far along these shows were in
production and how deeply these shows
were going to tie into their adjacent
film releases Falcon in the Winter
Soldier was in the middle of reshoots
wind production shut down some of the
cast reported that some key sequences
still needed to be shot war episodes
my hunch is that this storyline might
not have needed Black Widow to set it up
and if they can finish reshoot so I bet
it could still drop on Disney Plus
sometime late 2020 by the way Disney
sounds like they're still on track to
release the Mandalorians season 2 in
October on Disney Plus since they
wrapped production one division and Loki
or different stories one division has
wrapped production but based on Kevin
Feige announcement at Comic Con last
summer Wanda Maximoff was going to
the story of dr. strange in the
multiverse of madness so wanna vision
could stay in December 2020 or if they
want to use it to build a momentum for
multiverse of madness they could delay
it a year Loki was in the midst of
production when they halted everything
and with the time variance authority and
alternate timelines factoring in so
heavily to that plot it's possible that
story could have tied into the
multiverse of madness as well so you
might see Loki get pushed back to lately
21 along with Wanda vision the other
announced live-action Marvel Disney Plus
titles like Hawkeye Miss Marvel she
whole moon night none of those had
really begun production so I doubt we'll
see those before 2022 to me if the fact
that spider-man 3 was left off this list
is very telling because it showed us
that it's interconnectivity to past and
future MCU events might not be that
important to its story like spider-man 3
might just feature Peter Parker dealing
with Kraven the hunter or the sinister
six without calling the Avengers for
help that much and really I think this
means that we probably won't see Peter
Parker play a major role in the
multiverse of madness like multiverse of
madness probably won't be the rumored
Sam Raimi's fight over Siri that we've
speculated before with Tobey Maguire
cameos but rather a story that might
need the Eternals in shang-chi to
precede it and thor xi under to follow
it like this could mean the ancient
history the Celestials present in the
Eternals or the resurgence of the
mystical ten reins presented in
shang-chi could be part of the set up
for the multiverse drama that Doctor
Strange finds himself in and that
multiverse drama could be part of the
set up that sees Jane Foster wielding
Mjolnir in Love & thunder since we only
ER was shattered in the prime MCU earth
one nine nine nine nine eleven thunder
taking place in an Ultimate Marvel
reality could behind me only returns now
at the moment Pixar sole Christopher
Nolan's Tennant and Wonder Woman 1984
seem to still be coming out this summer
they could be delayed we'll see Disney
also announced that they would be
releasing Artemis Fowl on Disney Plus
could they do the same for Black Widow
hopefully but the fact that they shook
up their whole Marvel phase 4 timeline
just to ensure Black Widow open
theatrically on November 20 20 this
tells me that Disney is even further
from ever releasing Black Widow VOD on
Disney Plus like I have discussed the
economics of this before but Disney
still has a chance of Black Widow making
back its production and marketing costs
with a delayed global theatrical release
meanwhile streaming it on VOD even with
unprecedented rental rates in the
countries Disney plus is available would
still guarantee Black Widow loses
hundreds of millions of dollars by the
way they haven't spent nearly as
money producing marketing Artemis Fowl
do you never see an Artemis Fowl trailer
during the Superbowl
so stringing hats a no-brainer Black
Widow different story but hey the good
news of all this is that it gives us
even more time to go back and re-watch
the Infinity Saga
those are videos I have really been
enjoying making join our watch Long's
twice a week on discord I becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash new rock
stars comment down below with your
thoughts on all this follow me on
instagram twitter at EA boss for updates
on all this followed new rock stars and
subscribe to my rock stars to breakdowns
of everything you love thanks watching
bye
[Music]